[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream commemorative edition number
64. am i correct indeed today we
represent the perfect squares
64 is indeed a perfect square i am
something like an imperfect square so
it's sort of a yin yang
kind of a thing it is a gorgeous day
here
in portland i don't just mean nice i
mean it is a gorgeous day here in
portland
it is it is the kind that i imagine
makes
antifa help old ladies across the street
before burning them to the ground not
going there you're not going there all
right well
i'm not either then okay okay well
as usual uh we have a lot to talk about
uh shall i outline some of our topics
before launch
before we launch in great or do you have
something else to start with
no i think well maybe we should just
mention that um
greg gutfeld gave us he did a
best of 2020 list on his locals page
and he awarded the dark horse podcast
the best podcast
of 2020. is amazing thank you greg if
you're out there we really appreciate
that
um he gave eric the uh 2020 canary in
a coal mine award um i didn't know there
was an avian category maybe next year we
will get the uh
plain brown raptor award or something
like that that would be cool
um but uh yeah i thought that was injury
you want to show it zach
you do have a screenshot yeah there you
go
so he calls us uh retro mm-hmm um
the most retro but also relentlessly
engaging and i am i am your heather
heine
yes you are my heather hi there there's
some actually wonderful typos
there are some wonderful yeah that one
is particularly
particularly good and i will say greg
that actually
uh we will not relent we will attempt to
engage
you know from here on out really yeah
absolutely yep
okay all right so yes thank you thank
you for that
um okay so we're going to talk a little
bit about you know the u.s for those of
you in the united states which is
most viewers and listeners i believe
uh we got a new president this week and
we're going to talk a little bit i
saw that yeah you noticed yes i did yeah
so we're gonna
talk a little bit about some of the
things he's uh he's done so far
and um uh discuss
one of the major magazines in the united
states jumping the shark
um uh investigating just at the
anecdotal level how
different businesses might survive a
lockdown a series of lockdowns of this
length based on some conversations that
i had this week in
in portland um we're going to talk just
a little bit about what
is happening at powell's portland's
massive amazing independent bookstore
and uh what it suggests about how things
get reported
we are going to revisit unfortunately
the question of tech censorship because
there is
um there's been new new stuff happening
this week
and uh finish uh by
speaking just a little bit about the
advice of some doctors to quote trust
the science
they say the data is sick phenomenal
that sick is s-i-c yes i'm saying that
you are simply quoting their error
rather than making it
yeah so actually the sick is in
reference to the is r
distinction the data are phenomenal is
what they meant but they'd still be
wrong right yes but at a different level
differently wrong yeah um all right so
we got a new president
yes we do have a new president here this
on on wednesday to
um somewhat less fanfare than it would
be absent a pandemic of course
uh there were there were speeches and
then
shortly after um he he got right down to
it
and uh he shut down the dakota access
pipeline dapple
wait wait you're going to skip right
past the inaugural
that's what we had talked about doing
but before it got no i think we need to
mention that
this uh this speech was uh was given
quite a number of fascinating accolades
people were
very jazzed on the speech i was somewhat
less jazzed on the speech i didn't see
the whole thing because i
decided to play a little drinking game
where every time biden said unity i
would take a drink
and i made it that's why i found you on
the floor yes that's why i was passed
out there
but others thought the speech was
excellent uh i think we have a
quote here from john heilman zach could
you put that
up
on the larger screen if you would
oh that's good enough um john hileman
said
there was a lot about the speech that
was soaring it may have been the best
speech joe biden has ever given it
wasn't
it was important in that it was not a
political speech at all
it was a speech that had a much higher
purpose than that
and i don't want to go overboard and
compare it to lincoln's second inaugural
but aspirationally that's where it
wanted to live
and then he added actually [ __ ] lincoln
no he didn't no he didn't um that was
humor
but anyway yes this uh comparison to
lincoln's second inaugural which is of
course where
the famous quote about the better angels
of our nature comes from is completely
inappropriate and preposterous although
maybe not hard
to understand in light of president
trump's
this is now my opinion president trump's
appalling
speaking style um where you always had
the sense that he was
lecturing you about something he had
learned in a briefing 10 minutes ago
or not learned right or not completely
learned but in any case
yeah biden's speech was uh it was
competent and given how many gaffes we
saw on the campaign trail it was
uh maybe much better than it might have
been it was no doubt a return to a tone
of statesmanship
it was a return yes to the high
production values
of the blue team but
also i would say the degree to which
unity was
invoked so regularly and has been so
weaponized since the election
i i just find it uh kind of appalling
the abuse of that term and i
can't help but take it a little bit
personally
so that said he shut down dapple
which you know very good very good job
he
re-entered the us on the paris climate
accord awesome
very very nice he reestablished ties
with the who
the world health organization utterly
necessary
even even for those of us who have been
skeptical about some of the politization
that the who has engaged in um and he
signed this executive order
on preventing and combating
discrimination on the basis of gender
identity or sexual orientation
cool wait not cool
not cool yeah not well let's just read
the first paragraph good
okay uh zach you can show my screen
oops this is executive order from the
day of the inauguration january 20th
on as i said preventing and combating
discrimination on the basis of gender
identity or sexual orientation
excuse me by the authority vested in me
as president by the constitution and the
laws of the united states of america it
is hereby ordered as
follows section one policy
every person should be treated with
respect and dignity and should be able
to live without fear
no matter who they are or whom they love
children should be able to learn without
worrying about whether they will be
denied access to the restroom
the locker room or school sports adults
should be able to earn a living and
pursue a vocation knowing that they will
not be fired
demoted or mistreated because of whom
they go home to or because how they
dress does not conform to sex-based
stereotypes
people should be able to access
healthcare and secure a roof over their
heads without being subjected to sex
discrimination
all persons should receive equal
treatment under the law
no matter their gender identity or
sexual orientation
but first zach if i may thank you
that first sentence
even just the first two phrases of the
first sentences of this executive order
every person should be treated with
respect and dignity and should be able
to live without fear
is a completely honorable sentiment and
exactly not what this executive order
then proceeds to do
what it proceeds to do is prioritizes
the demands of a very very tiny minority
of people
over that over the rights the
established legal rights
of half of the population since when is
this what democracy looks like
well the problem of course is that you
can read that
in two different ways and it is in fact
i would argue
designed so that we will read it into
different ways that it is a signal to
those who are looking for a particular
change in the law
while appearing to subscribe to values
that all decent americans hold and
the problem is that there is a an
actually
difficult balance that needs to be
struck between
providing people the liberty to do
things like
transition to the gender that they feel
while protecting people who have a right
to be protected which is to say
women and so these things it is not
clear how to strike that balance and it
is certainly not
going to be a simple matter but in doing
it this way
they have effectively chosen sides while
leaving the option
to declare themselves completely
uh concordant with the
the values that we all share yeah the
rest of the executive order with one
notable sentence is pretty anodyne
right it just it's it's just it's fairly
generic and exactly as you say it leaves
them open
to declare later oh that's not what we
meant
oh we didn't see this eventuality coming
we couldn't have seen what was
downstream of this
and you know of course they can right
it's perfectly clear
that i'm in uh extending
effectively extending rights to trans
women these are people who are born male
who transition to female
that they are encroaching on
the rights of women to be protected from
men
in things like sports competition and
more importantly in
cases like uh when they are sent to
prison
prisons crisis centers um halfway houses
places places
that are single sex for the explicit
reason
that women are a protected class
and this has never before been a class
to which you could simply declare
yourself i am now in
that and um the the vast majority of
what you know what i will continue to
call the truly trans people and now i
don't have a you know
magic magic eyesight with which
determine
at first glance you know who that is but
i will say that the truly trans people
represent i am
certain a small fraction of the people
who are currently masquerading as trans
and um you know this we of course want
to protect
uh the rights and the health and the
safety of truly trans people
but doing so in a way that is easily
gameable
and will be gamed and allows those many
people who
are interested in cosplay to
to come into women's spaces is
frankly horrific and i don't understand
how anyone
who has claimed to be interested in
women's rights
or protections for women or a feminist
or any of this i don't see how
anyone and i am sure that biden and
harris both identify with those sorts of
identifiers
um can can be in favor of this if they
have thought even you know
two steps down the road well i don't
even think they are
in favor but i think they are playing
politics and
um there is a large segment of the
population that
can't track multiple competing values
simultaneously and so
there's a script that basically says you
know
if you're a good person you're in favor
of protecting trans people
i would agree with that but protecting
trans people if that's all you see at
that moment at whose expense and
just just to make this perfectly clear
why are women
a protected class and why does that
protection need to be maintained
especially in light of all of the gains
that women have made well
let me explain it this way um i liked
how that went
yeah i'm just having a little
conversation when i said you want to get
some coffee or something
you're uh you're welcome for you maybe
sure that'd be great
um but let's think about it this way
um at a basic biological
level right nature has not it has been
balanced in some ways
but it has been unfair to women in the
sense of rendering them
vulnerable you know there's the obvious
fact of males on average being bigger
but there is the slightly harder
to to grapple with fact of the
sexual asymmetry between men and women
which is to say
men are in a much better position
physiologically
to rape women than women are to rape men
right right a woman raping a man is a
difficult thing for her to accomplish
even if that's what she is
desiring to do and the advantages that
bad men will take of women are well
understood well named everyone is
familiar with them
and they are universally understood by
all but the reprehensible few to be
appalling and
and disgusting the power
that bad women have over men is less
well understood
uh has fewer names associated with it
and it doesn't tend to
it's not nearly as likely to end in
violence or unwanted pregnancy
yes and men you know they may not always
uh
resist bad women as they should but they
at least have that power at their
disposal whereas a man can overpower a
woman
um rape her and as you point out where i
was
gonna go next is the simple ability to
potentially inflict a child on someone
right that is a biological asymmetry now
it's reduced for people who
might avail themselves of uh you know
family planning technology
but nonetheless the the ability of you
know this
asymmetry between what a man can do to a
woman and what a woman could do to a man
is justification in and of itself for
protected spaces where women don't have
to worry
about people with male genitals and
gonads
and the idea that
we are somehow in an effort to be good
to a
small number of people who are
involved in a gender transition that we
are going to
open a loophole you know well no man
would exploit that
really an unscrupulous man wouldn't
choose
you don't even need to go to have you
met men have you met people of course
people will
you know meerkats would right giraffes
would this
you know this is what social organisms
do
some number of individuals in any social
system be they humans or dolphins or
rabbits
will game the system and you know create
a system that is gameable
by executive order and you're going to
get a lot more of it
right and you know an executive order
like this well if it doesn't draw
you know it ought to protect women in
sport right let's just agree that that
would be the right thing to do because
there are major
physiological differences that advantage
people born male
but if your executive order
doesn't recognize that there's a problem
when it comes to prisons
and that a man sent to a men's
prison for a sexual offense who suddenly
decides
that he's trans and prefers to be in a
women's prison
cannot be humored and in fact there are
multiple examples of men
who have done this and then gone on to
uh
to assault women so now it does i mean
it does
the actual manifestation seems to be
mostly at
um head of agencies you know so federal
federal agencies
um and i i do feel like it opens up a
whole lot of possibility for downstream
but i'm not sure
i'm not sure for instance what the
effect of this executive order
specifically would be on federal prisons
obviously on private prisons it has no
direct effect i'm not sure about federal
prisons because they're not
agency level well i'm not sure actually
that there's a distinction between
the private and the the publicly funded
prisons because the question is the
rights of the prisoners you know they're
sentenced in a
a public uh context and so
it doesn't say that the executive order
has an effect on prisons but it signals
a belief in a principle that obviously
is insufficient to deal with
the situation and so does that are they
going to reverse course on
this and say yes this is true equal
protection except when it comes to
prisons
no that's not very likely it's not very
likely and so they're effectively asking
the populace to
to buy into a fiction and the more
fictions
that people buy into the more of that
cognitive dissonance that they are that
all of us are asked to participate in
the more fractured our cognition gets
the less capable we are of having a
coherent worldview
and building it from first principles
and you
you're more likely once you know once
you've accepted some number of these
just
you know just lies about what reality is
you are more and more likely
to say you know whatever i i accept it
i'm going to go along with it because
you appear to be feeding me something
that's consistent in your world view and
i don't know how to make sense of it
yeah so you know we've seen
um a number of these signals about
direction and we've seen them all
delivered
in rorschach form and i think
um you know actually i don't know if
this is the place to introduce it but
um i did a discussion with uh james
lindsey
and jesse single and there's a segment
of it that keeps coming back up and
jesse has expressed frustration that he
keeps being drawn back into discussions
of it and i don't wish to draw him
back into a discussion okay uh so could
we just
so there's a more natural place to go
there i think perfect can we can we do
the next thing
first um if i if you were going where i
think you are
um there's a there's one more sentence
in the executive order that i wanted to
bring up which is you don't have to show
my screen zach
it is for example transgender black
americans face unconscionably high
levels of workplace discrimination
homelessness and violence including
fatal violence
now early in the summer when the
protests and then the riots were
beginning to become regular parts of
life in portland and many other cities
around the us and even the world
we pointed out here on
on this podcast that there was at that
point
on the black lives matter home page a
strange focus on what
what we suggested was a strange but
unusual notable focus on
black trans lives black trans lives
matter in fact there was a there was a
um an organized rally for black major
demonstration the second major one in
new york
yeah so black trans lives what what is
it about black trans like why
this intersectionality in particular and
um
you know there's there's a lot to do
there and i'm not sure this is where we
want to
explore that again but unconscionably
high levels of workplace discrimination
homelessness and violence is the claim
well unconscionably high levels is of
course a wiggle term
that you could claim unconscionably high
levels is any levels
and therefore any any violence against
pick your group
fill in your group here is
unconscionably high in which case
this is uh this sentence means nothing
in which case
why include it and what what they seem
to be doing is signaling that they are
making some kind of a statistical
argument without actually having done so
so they provided cover for themselves
as as you would if as you would if you
had no data
i really want to see the references i'm
i am so tired of seeing this claim
black trans lives are the ones who are
the most threatened there is an epidemic
and you know there are what 400 000
deaths in america that have been
attributed to covet at this point and i
didn't pull up the numbers but
something in the dozens at the most
of um trans people murdered in the u.s
last year which is you know the thing
that is evidence of the
epidemic of violence and hatred against
trans lives and often specifically black
trans lives and
you know that that many lives um
taken inappropriately terribly etc
is does not a pandemic make no no it
does not
um it's
it it makes you wonder who is served
right like who
who wins with this kind of rhetoric and
here um
here is where i think we can segue to
what you were going to talk about here
so andy now
you know our friend also um someone who
we'll talk about a little bit later with
regard to the the powell's
dust up um who is a
um portland-based or you know was in
portland for
for his whole life um based journalist
who focuses
on revealing what antifa is actually up
to and of course has
drawn the ire of of them many many times
and
sometimes public ways a couple of years
ago revealed the fabrications behind
the then ubiquitous claims it seemed
that there was
widespread street violence against trans
people in portland and seattle
and um i remember following this at the
time i think it was 2018 but actually
katie herzog and jesse single in their
podcast blocked and reported
we're talking about this this week and
they were talking about
the the good work that andy noe did
specifically
on revealing that a there was a clear
financial incentive
for such people to claim that they had
been assaulted because in
almost every case there was an immediate
gofundme set up with several thousand
dollars accruing pretty rapidly to the
person who had supposedly been assaulted
and there was a complete lack of
evidence there were never any police
reports
and of course people hide behind you
know all cops or bastards all of this
but
you know no evidence financial incentive
gee
i wonder if this is perhaps uh a
an epidemic of you know violence against
trans people on the streets of two of
the most progressive cities in the
country
um that is actually a fiction and um
andy certainly
um found evidence to suggest that that
is that it's likely what it serves also
to do though is not just enrich the
individuals who are making those claims
by lining their pockets with gofundme
money but it also
further creates this culture of fear and
anger
which allows you know a blue team and
red team
to go farther and farther apart and look
suspiciously at each other sometimes
armed
from ever greater divides yes and
um you know at some level the the
category is um
unassailable right why is it that black
trans lives
are somehow at the top of the stack well
this comes from intersectionality the
idea
that there is some sort of emergent
nature to the
overlapping oppressions that someone
experiences that you know the
the oppression of you know a black gay
person
is more than the sum of the oppression
of black and gay and no doubt there's
some truth to that but
you can't base policy on that and what's
more
you can't open a loophole based on it
and expect nobody to cynically go
through it
right so you know at some level
policy has to be color blind
right it is the blindness of the law
that is its genius
and all of these things that say
actually we can do better than blind we
can enhance it to protect this group and
that group and the other group
all of these things are an invitation
to gaming except in cases where as we
discussed at the top here
you know these things are uh objective
right
i am female therefore certain things
inherently follow and so anyway we just
got to stop being stupid about this if
you open a loophole there will be
people who use it to game the system and
the law has to be
robust to that it has to not allow it
yes
no that's that's actually that's
absolutely right and did you
want to then say something about um well
i wanted to clarify something without
uh you know jesse has ex uh jesse single
has
explained that he doesn't want to be
dragged back into this discussion um
while dragging me back into it but
nonetheless i do think it makes sense to
put off the discussion of who was
right in our uh in our argument
um until there's more information but i
want to make clear what my position
is and isn't because it gets caricatured
the
position that i laid out was so this is
a position you laid out in one of the
unity campfires
with jesse single and james lindsay back
in i don't know what it would have been
august or september maybe
i think it was later than that it was uh
pretty pretty late in the election
cycle but in any case um
jesse suggested that the term equity
didn't mean anything like what james and
i
thought it meant and um i said
something dismissive like you just wait
and see
equity is a very special term now
you will find equity in the executive
order
you will in fact find i believe a
definition of equity which is unusual
and a positive sign
um but um the
in the eo you think well it was
certainly it certainly came out of the
biden administration if it's not in the
eo it's somewhere else in the documents
uh that became uh visible in the first
couple days the word is here but there's
no definition okay
um in any case the position that
i want to be held to is this it is not
that equity
means one thing or the other it's that
equity
is a mon and bailly and that what we
should expect
is to find evidence on both sides equity
is simply what we would expect it to
mean based on common parlance something
very close to
equality or equity is a magic term
that allows all sorts of reorganization
of who's uh who's up and who's down
based on a desire to equalize
outcomes and that is the thing over
which um we are
really fighting so yes in the end
the fact that there is evidence this
week
of the biden administration taking a
very standard view of what equity is
the idea that it's basically equality um
that is to say equality of opportunity
and the fact that there is evidence this
week
that um equity means to them
some sort of equalized outcome
those are both present and that is
exactly what one expects so that is to
say
the safe version of the term right that
it is effectively equality of
opportunity
that's uh the mott and then the bailly
is um the much more the enhanced
powerful weaponized version of the term
and so in any case the real question is
what will the policy look like
to forestall one other thing that i'm
certain is coming down the pike i am
not saying that the biden administration
is
secretly super woke i don't think they
are
i think they're cynical as all hell and
what that means
is that they are going to but i mean so
are all the corporate brands
who are who are going you know balls out
on the woke
advertising they're not the people in
the
you know in in the big offices do not
actually believe this stuff
uh well i think that answer is more
complicated i think people talk
themselves into some stuff
um but it's the it's the rank and file
um
among you know the recently graduated
from crazy
college programs who are bringing it in
and who are the true believers
well i would say they bring it through
the door there's a credible threat
wielded under these terms and management
which may not inherently gravitate to
these things
then rationalizes them into their belief
structure but they may actually in some
very meaningful sense
believe these things before it's all
said and done yeah
nonetheless i want to say the um
the question my expectation is that
equity
intersectionality critical theory all of
these things will be signaled
they will be used to establish a
partnership which i believe
the dnc and the biden administration
will engage in without
a core belief but the prediction is
they do not know what they are
partnering with they don't understand
its power and they will not be able to
control it and therefore
it will end up transforming uh the
landscape more than it already
even has that said i think it is very
important
and i did this with trump also but it is
very
important to give the new administration
the benefit of the doubt
and to let them you know surprise us in
the positive
case absolutely so actually as per your
um your discussion there of the two
different
the modern bailey use of these terms uh
which is invisible to people who aren't
aware that there are two definitions
um there was this washington post
article from a few days ago so i could
just show my screen very briefly so
people can see what we're talking about
biden selects transgender doctor
rachel levine as assistant health
secretary
and i'm going to read just the second
paragraph before
giving my screen back dr rachel levine
this is
uh biden's words in a statement dr
rachel levine will bring the steady
leadership and essential expertise we
need to get people through this pandemic
no matter their zip code race religion
sexual orientation gender identity or
disability
and meet the public health needs of our
country in this critical moment and
beyond biden said in a statement
quote she is a historic and deeply
qualified choice to help lead our
administration's health efforts
end quote farther down in the article
we have her saying now not she is not
saying what she is intending to do but
she's talking about her work in
pennsylvania she says i am proud of the
work we have done as an administration
to address health equity and the work i
have done personally to raise awareness
about lgbtq equity issues she said
to which you know i ask which is it
you can't have it both ways here we have
these two things right next to each
other in
an article in a single article from
washington post
are is this person going to serve all
americans
regardless of demographic marker or are
they going to be working for equity
which explicitly centers these
demographic markers and seeks redress
for differences
in outcomes which is it regardless
of demographic marker as biden says or
focusing on demographic markers as she
implies
you can't have it both ways regardless
or focused regardless or focused
i really hope it's regardless those are
his words those are biden's words
there is nothing in what i have found of
what she has said in the past
levine the new assistant health
secretary to suggest that there is going
to be any regardless here
well also there is the fact of her
nomination
to the post which i will say
um would be striking
under ordinary circumstances and appears
to be very questionable
in the midst of a pandemic that is
bringing us to our economic knees among
other things
that this you know it is obviously
possible that she is the very best
person
for that post at this moment and just
happens to be trans
i don't see any evidence to that effect
so
one has to imagine that even in the
midst of this pandemic the choice was
made to signal something
about gender identity rather than figure
out
whoever the top person for this post
would have been
on the merits and that is a very
disturbing sign
and uh i'm going to go full turf here
okay
and then you're going to riff a little
bit on on what that means
um wapo in an article from four years
ago
uh this is 2016 at the point that she
was appointed um
in pennsylvania let me share this just
briefly zach meet rachel levine one of
the very few transgender public
officials in america
and this is from june 1st 2016. this is
this is while obama was still president
in this article we have um levine
being revealed as having some
traditional markers of femininity
apparently quote she favors chunky
necklaces in earl grey tea and is in
constant motion
but later in the same article levine
does not discuss whether she took
hormones or had surgery calling it a
private medical matter
you can't actually change your sex if
you're a mammal
it's never happened you can change the
presentation
the way that you appear that is gender
in order to be welcome
in some female spaces
there is no way that self id should be
sufficient
and claiming that the actual
hormonal and surgical changes which do
not get you all the way to changing sex
but get you into a position of actually
in my mind
being transgendered if that's
private and all you have to do is wear
chunky necklaces and drink earl grey tea
to be considered female and then um now
we've got this
female person as assistant health
secretary well that's you know chalk one
up to feminism
no this is this is backwards land in so
many ways and this is yet another one of
these places
where people who aren't thinking too
hard about it sort of see this go
what okay okay i guess
oh no one knows if this person is even
on
hormones of the sex they weren't born to
or has had any surgery maybe they're
just
drinking tea and wearing necklaces and
that's enough to get them called a woman
didn't know it was so easy yeah it's a
it's an amazing feat um
so you describe yourself as having gone
full turf
yeah um turf for those of you who have
been living under a rock
um it means uh it's a it's an acronym
trans-exclusionary radical feminist
and my contention is that we can prove
that that's not actually a thing
awesome and here's how we can do it
um one says certain things in
the public sphere and this accusation
comes back you and i have both had it
hurled at us
many many times and we know many other
people who have
as well um what one needs to do
in order to have that term hurled at you
is espouse a belief that simply saying
that you are of one gender or the other
is not sufficient and that uh some
people will if you say that it is
sufficient if that's the standard you
legally adopt that there are those who
will game the system
and already are
and if you say those things you will be
labeled as a trans exclusionary radical
feminist which is an accusation akin
in some circles to being called for
example a racist
right it's a it's clearly understood to
be a kind of bigotry but here's the
problem
is if those are the only things that you
need to believe in order to be in this
category
then you don't need to be trans
exclusionary
right you don't need to be radical and
you don't need to be a feminist as a
matter of fact if you just simply
believed what pretty much everybody
believed 10 15 years ago
you'd be right there in turf land plenty
of conservatives this was your point to
me earlier plenty of conservatives
have this same sense of like when did we
stop
not understanding biology and many
conservative people would
not call themselves radical feminists
right
simply traditional view of gender roles
which isn't where you and i come from
but
well they may have a traditional role
right
view of gender roles this this just
requires actually nothing about gender
roles
it requires understanding biology well
right you could come there from biology
you could come there from
uh you know just simply having a belief
in
traditional roles that are you and i
would say are
antiquated but any of those things are
good enough to get you through the door
so the point is
none of the letters in the acronym are
required to be in the category it's a
special category it's like equity it's a
magic term
and in this case what that magic term is
doing
is it is standing like a buzz saw on the
side of an argument space and the idea
is
you are limited to certain arguments but
if you make any of these
other arguments then we're going to
shove you into that thing we're going to
shove you into the bigot
saw yeah and at some level we have no
choice but to stare this down
turf isn't a thing just because a group
of people have decided to
equate it with bigotry and then accuse
people of it as they find convenient
doesn't make it true it doesn't create
any validity and what's more we can tell
it's invalid
because even by its own definition it
doesn't add up because there's so many
people in the category who are none of
those things
yeah well i mean i do feel like there's
a way in which we're living in an age of
legitimized epithets against women you
know turf
karen right like you know these these
are epithets
pure and simple but of course um you
know those are the two that come to mind
and there's plenty
that are hurled at people regardless of
their sex
you know the fact that the fact that you
can be a nazi for
um for saying that equality of um
outcome is not a legitimate goal is is
rather remarkable and it acts as that
same kind of buzzsaw
yeah i agree it's a general form of
argument
um and you know there are variations on
the theme i would say
uh ibram x kendi's formulation about
there is nothing everything is either
racist or anti-racist and therefore if
you can't say that something is
anti-racist well we know what category
it's in
yeah i mean that's a very special form
of logical argument
by the way uh dr candy if you are
watching and i hope you are
we can also prove very simply in a way
that every single person who hears it
will understand
why it is the correct uh logical
formulation we can prove
that your contention that there is no
non-racist that there is only
racist racist and anti-racist we can
prove
that that is incorrect and i would like
to offer you
if you'd like to come on the dark horse
podcast i'd love to have you on
you can outline your position i will
outline
my challenge to it and we can see
which argument wins out
all right um should we move on yeah
let's do that all right uh
here we have uh zach if you will
show my screen this is the guardian
uh rolling stone seeks thought leaders
willing to pay two thousand dollars to
write for them
this is i think rolling stone one of one
of the most important journalistic
outlets actually of um of at least the
late 20th century
jumping the shark this is
truly remarkable actually that they are
willing to have pay-for-play content
masquerading to anyone but careful
readers
as presumably next to
their normal content although it's not
totally clear from this
and uh so zach yeah thank you
there
magazines have a long history of
establishing and you know women's
magazines have a much harder time with
this
historically where advertisers have
declared
themselves uh privy to making decisions
about editorial content on the same page
where ads show
but other than women's magazines
typically these journalistic monthly and
weekly magazines
have a kind of firewall between content
and advertisers and rolling stone is
saying no
no firewall paywalls are fine but no
firewall
right like we are we are not going to
anymore protect our readers
uh from from recognizing
when it is that someone some
self-declared leader in
i can't remember it was like um
the the types of things that they are
saying
um the invitation to possible members
says that the scheme is strictly for
those in the quote
worlds of music entertainment food
beverage and cannabis so
self-styled or simply pr hacks for any
of these industries for some firm at any
of these industries
um gets to you know pay two thousand
dollars and
right pieces that serve the serve that
industry serve those corporations and
that's not what rolling stone ever was
until well today
well it's also a beautiful loophole all
you got to do is get sufficiently stoned
and you're qualified to write for them
which
well i mean any anyone is qualified
really um you know
yes all you have to do is say it's about
music entertainment food beverage or
cannabis
and have two thousand dollars to spend
yeah so
and and then then rolling stone will
sort of
kind of call you a thought leader why
because you had two thousand dollars to
spend
that's what makes you a thought leader
so there's a question really about
what's
driving this um one thing is that these
journalistic outlets and you're right
rolling stone has been
uh a a leading publication um it's had
some hiccups in
recent years but um you know matt taube
for example has
has been there and has done tremendous
work uh reporting on the financial
crisis among other things russia gate
etc
but um you know our best journalists
are fleeing to sub-stack
yep right you know we've got uh glenn
greenwald fleeing the intercept we've
got matt taibbi
on uh substance i think he may still be
at rolling stone but he's
uh partially on sub stack not sure um
barry weiss left the new york times uh
andrew sullivan is on sub stack
so we have many of our greatest writers
there
yeah why why wouldn't they be
sought after by these major publications
in a way
that would allow them to uh you know
write their own tickets sufficiently
that they could be under one of these
mastheads the answer is um telling the
truth is incompatible with
the business model that these
establishments now have
they are hemorrhaging uh serious readers
because those serious readers aren't
interested in
hearing the you know the whether or not
joe biden's
wristwatch is a rolex and what that
implies about his view of the poor
whatever crazy crap it's gonna be next
and people are now sourcing their own
news that they're paying quite a bit
really and they should
frankly the value that you get from
signing up with any of those people on
substance is
incredibly high because they're
incredibly insightful and you know
they're each of them one off and you
know very special cases so
you know i think this is a you know a
ham fisted
crazy attempt to figure out what
substance
is doing right and try to get a piece of
that action which isn't going to work
but you know is it the finances that are
driving this
you know is it the attempt to get people
to cough up the two thousand bucks
because if you get enough of those
maybe it adds up is it the attempt to
bootstrap some new model of
journalism which obviously it's not
journalism this isn't
yeah um so anyway i don't know what's
driving it it's so new i mean in fact
it's so crazy that
when i read it i thought they were
looking for people to pay
and no that's obviously not what's going
on yeah no there
i i also had that same misread for you
know a
fraction of a minute um because it
it is that surprising that rolling stone
would go down this red
yeah yeah so you called it uh you said
they had jumped the shark
i did and i it occurs to me that there's
something that has always bothered me
about that phrase
it's not the same damn shark they're
jumping they're jumping
a shark jumped a shark they've jumped a
shark or they're engaged in shark
jumping i think that works too
well i mean given the nature of
hollywood and that there was at the
point that happy days that fonzie in
fact did jump that original shark
um i imagine that they may have actually
used the shark
that had been used in jaws so it may it
may be
that there has been a shark uh that has
been used
yeah but you don't metaphorically jump a
literal shark oh that's probably true oh
yeah no i don't think they use that what
the rolling stone probably would but if
you imagine up in your head that same
shark even if you don't recognize that
it is the same shark that jaws and
fonzie shark are in fact the same shark
aren't you in fact still jumping
metaphorically jumping the shark
it's the world's only celebrity shark so
there's a good chance if you're jumping
a particular shark it's going to be that
one
but on the other hand um the
shark that rolling stone has jumped here
um
i believe is just sort of in the general
category that's a different shark
okay fair enough next topic
um so i spent um i spent some time
walking around portland um downtown the
southwest and the northwest
um this week so pearl district northwest
district
alphabet district and um
we wanted to talk about a few things
that emerge from that uh the second
is what has been going on at pals
lately and what i saw when i actually
went by pals a couple of times in the
last week and a half
but the first is really just it's based
on two anecdotes um
two business owners whom i talked to
because i walked into their stores
and one of whom is going out of business
one of whom is losing her store and one
of whom
is doing fine by her estimation and i
and i believe it to be true
um and they and i actually had both of
these conversations yesterdays um so
they're geographically close
they are geographically very close they
are demographically very similar both in
terms of the business owners themselves
and the businesses these are both uh
women's clothing stores
and they are women um actually i i know
one of their ages exactly and one of
them i'm just guessing
they're probably you know women around
around our age through you know gen x
um and you know been in portland for
a while and um you know
small independent women's clothing
boutiques
um both of them have been where they are
for
more than a decade in one case um
several decades
in fact it's being run um by the
daughter of the woman who originally
started it
and that one the one that's being run by
the daughter of the woman who originally
started it
is going out of business it's closing
its doors
uh it just it it's been it's been too
many months of hemorrhaging
without um you know in a in a high rent
area
uh without enough sales and you know
part of part of it is that that
particular store
uh caters specifically to higher end you
know sort of fancier
fancier dress and in an era of zoom zoom
meetings
um you know maybe you need a top once in
a while maybe um but
you know if you can sell tops and
sweatpants it's you know that that may
be the
the magic thing um whereas the other
store
um which is also actually in a slightly
lower rent
um area but but just just a few blocks
away but that you know that's that's the
way of
many urban areas
the difference between these two stores
other than that that small difference
is i think that the proprietor the owner
of the store that is doing okay is not
just
an entrepreneur and a retailer she is
also a creator and a designer and a
maker
so she designs much of the clothing that
she sells and she makes it herself and
she employs seamstresses who are also
doing some of the making
and um that you know when i when i
talked to her about it you know she
attributed her success to being stubborn
she says you know when things get tough
i
rise to the challenge and i just claw my
way out i fight my way out and there is
something to that
um to to the value of stubbornness in
the face of difficulty
for sure um but i think i would
attribute
i would put even more of the explanatory
um
power of you know why it is that she is
succeeding where
others are not uh to the fact that she
is actually creating something new in
the world
rather than than just you know just
being a curator and um and a
and a creator of a space where people
can come to to to buy things
and in particular uh
she told me that you know last spring
when the lockdowns were starting
um that's that is the season for her
i've never been in um the store before
this that's the season for her
when she is beginning to get um special
orders
for you know spring and summer weddings
for
for dresses um presumably for both
wedding dresses and
um you know bridesmaids dresses and just
special event stresses because spring
and summer
is is the time for these you know fancy
events and
of course those you know the ones that
she had that she hadn't started got
cancelled they all just you know went to
zero because suddenly these events were
no longer able to happen
and uh it looked really dire there
but she pivoted remember she's someone
who makes things and who employs people
as well
and they started making masks and they
started making
really high quality masks with layers of
filter in them that are comfortable that
are beautiful they're at a price point
that makes sense and it's not as
cheap as you can buy a mask but they're
but they work and she was able to not
just
keep her store and keep her living but
also keep the
the women whom she had already been
employing employed
because and you know she also had an
established enough business she already
had a web presence she already had an
instagram account you know she already
had all this stuff going
but absent the ability to actually be
making
things herself designing and making
things herself
i don't think the story would have gone
that way and um
i guess this is this is such a
challenging
era for everyone but almost everyone
should be able to find something in
themselves that is unique that they can
bring
to to the world and that that is what
everyone should be trying to figure out
what that thing is if they don't already
know it and how is it that they can
release in the world
as opposed to relying on supply chains
and the words of authority and you know
when am i going to be allowed to do the
thing that i was
that i was being allowed to do before
because it's not reliable
so it strikes me that this mirrors
something that
um we frequently said in the teaching
context
which is that the um
in an environment where you don't know
what world you're going to graduate into
because things are changing so quickly
it doesn't make sense to in
to invest deeply in specific knowledge
which you want to invest in is a
generalist toolkit and specifically
tools
that is to say things that you can apply
to whatever world that's likely to be
so as much as much inc has been spilled
over
learn to code the thing is if you know
how to code
then you can adapt to whatever world
whatever it is that needs to be coded in
the world that we find ourselves in
and so this is very much um
in contrast to the fashion of recent
decades educationally which has involved
you know a kind of slavish devotion to
the job
market and you know training it has
become increasingly
about training and has departed from
uh the the essence of of liberal arts
people are
you know starting earlier and getting
narrower and narrower training rather
than broader and broader training
because
what they want is a guarantee they want
to train for the job that they really
think is going to be there but then if
it shifts a little bit to the right
there's nothing yeah so um i think
you're
you're this is as close to a you know
controlled
comparison as you're going to get in the
circumstances and it tells that same
story
and i don't think the two things the
tenacity
and the flexibility are so different
because and and yet most people would
hear those two things and think that
they were
inverse somehow right not invert but
like at least distantly related
right and in fact they're directly
related because to the extent
that what you do is figure out how to
apply what tools you have to what
problems
exist you run up against lots and lots
of obstacles
and if your sense is uh this is
insurmountable then you won't be able to
wield those tools but your senses i know
there's a way around this and i'm going
to figure out what it is and i'm going
to make a prototype and it's going to
teach me
the next thing that that is the pattern
that actually makes you
uh capable of bootstrapping your new
role in
a hyper novel world that's right
um so also while walking around
um i specifically went by powell's
which is this um this amazing
gigantic independent bookstore in
portland i um
in in the before times i would spend a
lot of time
just just wandering around there um and
it's you know it's so big
um that you really you you kind of have
to choose a section
um you can't you can't possibly see all
of it and
um and it
i don't even know if it got into the
news in this last two weeks
i know that we became aware that there
were riots outside of it
um because of uh because of our
connection with andy andy no um so do
you want to set this up do you want to
explore what it is that you understand
so what happened um most of the people
who watch this podcast will know and in
fact i believe andy was my first
guest um back in the the early days of
dark horse
um andy is a local independent
journalist who has been
absolutely dogged about revealing what
is taking place
on the streets of portland when the
mainstream news was absolutely
pretending that it wasn't happening so
throughout
the uh the rioting um andy was there and
he was one of the few places you could
go to figure out
what was occurring in the streets of
portland
um he's got it he's got a bias he's got
a slant he's
um unapologetically conservative and he
sees um nothing to recommend what antifa
are doing and it's unlikely if they
started to do anything started doing
things that were recommendable that he
would
be the first to notice but you know what
his bias is
and he doesn't he doesn't hide it well
uh
there's there's more to say here i think
you know
um i would say uh douglas murray
has a bias but he navigates it in a way
that um never troubles me
um or at least not that i've seen
andy is not the same there's some places
where andy has done some things that
make me
recoil a bit on the other hand i would
point out
that andy is in a very vulnerable
position
he's on the ground here in portland
where he is
absolutely loathed by his subject right
as he is
looking at the violence on the streets
of portland they are out to get him
his his murder is being called for in
graffiti around downtown
it's really a very difficult situation
at the same time
he is um bootstrapping
a method of feeding himself in other
words as an
there is no niche for the independent
journalist on the ground
uh reporting on a mob that hates him and
wants him dead
but he's doing it and so while on the
one hand
i think it is important you know to
figure out how to keep one's biases out
of one's reporting and i
i want andy to do that i also recognize
that he has been able to do what nobody
else is able to do which is to report
that this story
on the ground consistently in spite of
tremendous danger
uh to him and his family and so
anyway i'm i'm rooting for for him to
find a model that allows him
uh to you know we all have our biases
but
if you're a reporter uh got to keep them
out of your reporting
nonetheless andy has been reporting this
story he has a book
coming out i believe the title is
unmasked unmasked inside antifa's
radical plan to destroy democracy
so which sounds like absolute hyperbole
until you talk to some antifa folks and
you discover that actually
they'll tell you that uh they're more or
less you mean they
burn flags repeatedly in front of the
courthouse here and all that and on
inauguration day
um they had an another protest saying um
i think you know [ __ ] biden um yeah
they're no more interested in peace now
than they were during the trump era
right and the
alignment uh you know people should go
back to my discussion
uh with jeremy lee quinn to get the you
know there is an ancestral relationship
between antifa and anti-racism which i
didn't know
but nonetheless the confluence of blm
and antifa is more or less accidental
um and they have now more or less parted
company in portland for
you know reasons that are easily
understood but
in any case um so andy has the book
coming out
uh in like april i think something oh
february i don't know
um and wouldn't you know it antifa
oh no let's go back to the the
inauguration day right the inauguration
day
riots here in portland were actually an
attack on the democratic party
headquarters locally
um you know not symbolic they broke
windows
clearly the same same violence we see
from them routinely
and there were banners in front uh
that said we are ungovernable right they
are declaring
the equivalent of war on the structures
that allow us to function as a society
they are
anarchists even though they uh claim
when
we say things like that that we don't
know what we're talking about but no by
the
deaf and by the self-definition of
anarchists they meet it right and just
and declaring yourself ungovernable
uh makes the subtitle here a radical
plan to destroy democracy
makes sense yep makes sense um so in any
case
uh very important that a guy like andy
with first-hand knowledge
of this has a book coming out not at all
surprising
that the subjects of his book who are
not flatteringly portrayed i don't know
how you would flatteringly portray them
but
right you know but he makes no attempt
to make no attempt to he
routinely uh reveals what they're up to
how violent it is and it
destroys their narrative that they are
responding to federal fascism or
whatever
um but they don't want that book sold at
powell's
books in downtown portland shocking
i'm terribly surprised that they are
against the publication and sale of this
book
right what is shocking
is that powell's has responded to this
with something other
than a vigorous dispense uh defense of
free speech
yeah so um they have a long
thing online pals does in response um
but the first paragraph and you can you
can show my
screen if you want zach powell's
commitment to free speech
dear pals community at pals a lot of our
inventory is hand selected and hand
promoted
and a lot of our inventory is not
unmasked by andy now came to us via
one of our long-term and respected
publishers hatchet book group
we list the majority of their catalog on
pals.com automatically as do many other
independent and larger retailers
we have a similar arrangement with other
publishers since i'll just go one more
um one more paragraph here since sunday
palace has received hundreds of emails
calls and social media comments calling
for us to remove
unmasked from pals.com due to protests
outside our burnside location that's an
auxiliary location
we have chosen to close our store
including curbside pickup to keep our
employees and customers safe
we are monitoring the situation daily
and we will reopen when it is safe to do
so
our other locations and website remain
open so it goes
it goes on and it's all this very
very back-pedalling soft like
mealy-mouthed kind of defensive free
speech
and the first day i went down to pals
the main one
downtown pearl district they were closed
and i was shocked i i was i was
interested
interested to see what it was going to
look like there and
presumably because it was closed there
was nothing going on at all except i was
standing there reading this sign on
their door
when a couple of other women came up
behind me and murmured oh
i wanted to go in i wish it were open
it's seeming not to know
why they were closed because there's
nothing there was nothing on the sign
outside the door on the door that
explained were closed because a mob came
and tried to censor us
like try right like this this was this
is about
one of the world's i think biggest
independent booksellers
responding to cries to not sell a book
right and their defense is
we didn't pick it it's in the catalog we
sell lots of things from catalog we're
never gonna have hard copies in the
store don't worry about that
right like people can still order it
online from us
if they if they need to we wouldn't but
if they need to right but certainly you
don't want it you know you can't buy it
in the store
and we will reopen when it's safe
effectively giving antifa control
over when powell's is open and when not
well they were open then a few days ago
um
and nothing nothing was happening right
but my point is to even say that
yes it reveals the failure of the full
stack here because what's really going
on
you know yes powell should make a
full-throated defense of free speech and
it should say
you know books are about ideas we do not
vet them in advance you are more than
welcome to purchase a copy of the book
disagree with it in whatever way
you wish and you know you have numerous
freedoms that would allow you to
write a vigorous response which we would
also carry blah blah blah blah blah
right they could do a lot of things
what's really happened here is the
mayor who said one
heartening thing about enforcing the law
after the election
and then basically things have gone back
to the way they were
beforehand with the uh kid gloves and
and all um but
because we are not enforcing the law and
because
a violent group is allowed to attack
a bookstore so that it does not carry a
a book
by a journalist who was exposing that
very
group right this is just this is the
collapse of civil society this is
not only you don't necessarily have the
right to speak
but um you are subject
to effective violent editing by exactly
those
on whom you report right so um
this is the failure of freedom of the
press it is the failure
of our governance structure yes powell's
is a private entity but
our city government is not and it has
obligations to
uh to protect uh andy and it has
obligations to protect peoples and if it
can't do it here
right if the city government do it for
powell's then portland is doomed right
like powell's is extremely popular with
portlanders they are rightly proud of
powell's this amazing
destination for tourists when there were
tourists yeah it is it is one of the
shining examples
of a a a brilliant non-chain
bookstore and
therefore if mayor wheeler were to
have the police enforce the law and
protect
powell's this is the thing that is most
likely to wake people up
to where we have where we where we find
ourselves
and it's not happening so it's not
happening it's not this
what if not this what exactly and i
guess the one other thing this made me
think about was the nature of episodic
behavior
and you know we spoke a lot during the
summer and the early fall when the
protests were still happening
every night in portland and they
reliably as the sunset became riots
and yet um some i don't know how many of
them were simply confused
how many of them were intentionally
being deceptive but some journalists
would say well
here i am at noon in some random square
and i don't see any protests so i guess
this is a lie i don't see any riots
and you know the idea that something has
to be happening at all times everywhere
in order to be happening at some time
somewhere is obviously a ridiculous
proposition
and if you say it that way it's revealed
but somehow most people
can't keep that very simple fact in
their head for very long
so you know were were those protests
mostly peaceful
well actually in portland every single
night they became
they went from peaceful to not peaceful
every single night
like clockwork it was actually more like
sun work because as the
time of the sunset changes so did the
time of the onset of the riots
it was regular it was predictable and
all you had to do
was be in the quote unquote right place
at the quote unquote right time
to see what was going on and if you
didn't go there
at that time in those places then you
wouldn't see and of course there were
actually
three or four or five regular locations
that the that the violence was happening
um mostly peaceful well
you know by some metrics i guess if you
want to do the math that way but that's
not journalism
is it and you know this maybe this is
totally irrelevant but
um i was reminded actually of um
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy of
douglas adams
fabulous uh five book trilogy
um uh with regard to the
uh the double entry that earth gets on
the hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy so
if memory serves it's been a while
um ford prefect who's actually an alien
um that has picked the um he thinks
unassuming name ford prefect with which
to live
on earth for it turns out decades
because he misses his
he misses right he misses his ride right
so he's stuck there and he befriends
arthur dent
and um the two of them managed to hitch
a ride on a vogon spaceship i think you
know within minutes of ruth's
destruction
um and the hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy is then both the book that ford
prefect is writing for
um but also encyclopedic it's an
encyclopedic
reflection of all of you know if if you
were hitchhiking around the galaxy where
might you go and
what might you do in order to find drink
food and yes
you suck on your towel to get nutrients
all of this um
when he was sent to earth to update the
entry the
entry for earth read harmless
and through dent of decades of work
um he managed to double the length of
the entry
to mostly harmless and i think
mostly harmless accurately describes
earth about as well
as mostly peaceful describes the
protests and riots
that have been happening in the u.s
since the end of may yes
i i agree with you now that you say it
douglas adams seems to have anticipated
this foolish moment
yeah sorry he's not here to see oh i am
uh i am too
okay we got two more topics um before we
sign off for the week
um we want to talk a little bit about
the newest uh iteration of tech
censorship that's happening
yes so this week uh our good friend
jim rutt and my
collaborator in game b back in 2013 i
think it was
um before that was before that well
anyway
uh jim rutt who was the organizer of
game b just to give you a sense of
who he is he is a former head former
chairman
of the santa fe institute which is an
academic institute that
is dedicated to the study of complexity
science
he is a tenacious student
of history he is also this is just a bit
of trivia
he is the coiner of the term snail mail
so in any case that's and you've been on
his podcast
i have been on his podcast a couple
times uh and
uh he is somebody who emerged from the
right
and uh anyway game b was an effort to
figure out how
to move civilization into its
2.0 version
uh that involve people from across the
political spectrum gathering in uh
stanton virginia the idea being that
game a which we are all living
is failing us in ways that we are
beginning to see and will begin to fail
everyone in ways that we are trying to
predict
but whether or not we predict it
accurately we know that it will fail
um yes uh the central idea
in game b was that game a is actually
vulnerable to competition it tends to
stamp out things that it can't fight but
if you were able to fight it
uh uh in on a level playing field
a game b that was superior at doing all
the things game a claims it wants
could could defeat it game b i should
say i believe the term
was uh was the insight of our friend
jordan
hall who was also a founder of
game b in any case jim was
thrown off of facebook this week he was
thrown off curiously in exactly the way
that i had been thrown off i believe he
saw even
to the word the same warning that i got
um and received the same non-explanation
of uh having violated
guidelines and he was told that there
was nothing that could be done that
there was
that the review had already been
conducted and there was no reversal
possible
we of course raised a stink about this
on
twitter and he has been reinstated
two of the mods
the admins for the game b facebook group
not a group i participate in but
nonetheless there is a group that um
discusses game b on facebook they were
thrown off at the same time
so jim and the other two admins yeah
they're all thrown off and
in the space between my being thrown off
and then restored and jim being thrown
off
jordan had been thrown off jordan hall
jordan hall so
this is a has his account been restored
it has been restored so
this is a fairly clear attack on
game b and the the thing that
is i think most significant here is that
we are watching
a purge of what we are told is
conservatives
that's a very upsetting idea the idea
that that a
political belief a mainstream political
belief like conservatism
is enough to get you thrown off of tech
platforms is
very disturbing and that ought to put
all of us from across the political
spectrum
on high alert but my claim is it's also
not true
it's not true that's the cover story
it's true
and yes conservatives are threatened but
really
those who are being thrown off are
anybody who
is a threat to the power of the ruling
elite which at the moment is
overwhelmingly from the blue team
so the blue team is consolidating power
by getting rid of things
that challenge it not only does that
include
uh yes jim was originally a conservative
i would now say he
is extremely progressive i mean after
all he was
interested in a total revamp of the way
civilization works to make it
fairer and more functional and safer um
that's pretty darn progressively
attempted progress
right um i also knowing him personally
knows that he
uh is an egalitarian who holds our
deepest liberal values close to his
heart
so game b threatened right
have numerous uh people associated with
game b thrown off of
facebook the unity movement was of
course suspended at twitter and remains
suspended to this day also not a
conservative
movement a non-ideological nonpartisan
movement
and so it's very clear that what's
happening here
is power is using weaponry to defend
itself
against challenge and to the extent that
many people
who are not paying close attention and
who are signed up with the blue team
are going to look past this and not
think about it they're going to turn a
blind eye
because what they think is happening
they may understand it's unfair but they
think that the cost is going to
conservatives
that is a an oversight that they will
soon enough regret so my suggestion
would be
follow all of the heterodox voices that
you believe
are honorable and do so across as many
channels
as you can so that as we get booted off
of one channel there's some place
that we can regroup and in later
podcasts we can talk about some
uh other technologies and approaches
that we might use
in order to protect ourselves from an
onslaught that we may only be able to
stave off very briefly
coming soon i hope right yes the
particular conversation that you are
alluding to
yes awesome okay one more thing
um
go ahead and show my screen zack this is
from the oregon coronavirus update
the um the newsletter that i get as a
citizen of oregon that i signed up for
um from the oregon department of human
services
january 21st that's two days ago as we
are speaking
we have this headline vaccine voices i
trust the science and the data
is phenomenal i'm going to read the
first sentence only
anna antonopoulos a pediatric
hospitalist in medford shares her
vaccination story
quote i got my coven 19 vaccine to
protect my patients my
friends my family and myself i've
dedicated my life to helping others
around me whether that is treating
patients in the hospital teaching sunday
school at church
being a super aunt to my five nieces and
two nephews and just being a good
neighbor and friend
getting my vaccine is an extension of
this i want to be an example
i trust the science and the data is
phenomenal i was so excited to get my
vaccine
she is making a public health
pronouncement
which is that being a good neighbor
means that you should seriously consider
getting the vaccine
and that may well be true
that is different public health is
different from what is the science
what do the science scientific results
actually say
and the quote that this begins with i
trust the science and the data is
phenomenal again i'm going to get a
little um
semantic here and say what that should
read is the data are phenomenal
um the singular being datum
now data r um but
we talked last week about um there being
i think it was last week a death and
there have been a few
um that seemed to be the result of this
vaccine but there are
many millions of of doses of vaccine
that have been
have been given and um you know it's an
error just as it is with kova to only
talk about deaths but if you just look
at the
the death rate the you know the the rate
of deaths that we
really think could be attributable to
the vaccine it's tiny and there will
always be some risk and
those deaths do not in and of themselves
um
really suggest any reason to be
particularly skeptical of this vaccine
at all the fact is and we have said this
over and over and
over again that given that the
technology with which
the two main vaccines that are being
deployed in the u.s the mrna vaccines by
pfizer and moderna
are brand spanking new that we simply
cannot have access to data
that suggest long-term safety those data
cannot possibly exist the data are
phenomenal
what data the data on what has happened
in the weeks to coming on you know
almost a month now of many many people
getting this vaccine
so far so good great really hope it
stays that way
but claiming that you should trust the
science and following that immediately
with the data are phenomenal
is disingenuous at best you
you you just can't get there from
here yeah i fully agree with you the
data can't be phenomenal because
they simply cannot cover one of the very
important issues which is what is the
long-term
uh impact of this on the physiology of
those
who have taken the vaccine hopefully
it's a
negligible effect but we can't know that
yet and pretending that we do know it
um is is unacceptable um
i would also say that this is embedded
in a landscape
where the data generation mechanism
is itself captured yeah and
that is very troubling because even when
the data do
seem to suggest a rosy outcome one
cannot be certain whether or not
that is what the data say because that's
actually the
consequence or because the economic
pressure economic pressures that come
from generating vaccines like this in a
for-profit
context have steered the journals have
caused
um a you know selection of some data
over others because they paint a rosier
picture
i'm not saying that has happened but we
have seen indications
of it and we've covered them here on the
podcast the fact is
this is not a clean system and if the
next time this happens
we want to be able to say what it is
that the
the data indicate then we need to clean
up that system so that in fact we can
say
you know okay we still wouldn't know
what the long-term impact was but at
least we'd be able to say with some
confidence
that an objective analysis says x y or z
and at this moment we don't have that
because the whole system is driven by
perverse incentives
yeah and it renders pronouncements by
any and all health officials pretty much
a suspect and you know we we should
always
be encouraged to remain skeptical of
pronouncements uh
that we have not ourselves uh
verified or um had people whom we have
come to trust
uh go in and assess those statements
uh in this case over and over and over
again i feel like we're beginning to
sound like a broken record here but over
and over and over again
we get health professionals of of some
stripe
who have been asked to make a statement
which basically demonstrates to all the
plebes all of us out here
why it is that we need to take this and
there is
you know the best possible gloss that i
can put on this is that there is
an intentional fuzzing of the actual
distinction between
um what could the science possibly say
about safety and efficacy of this
vaccine versus
what is the right public health move for
as many people as possible
um to do and those two things
um it's great when they're exactly in
concert they often will not be
and the fact is that we deserve as
members of a
democracy to have the information
on both fronts what can we and
can we not yet know about safety and
efficacy
and what is it that
we currently think is the best move from
a public health perspective that will
allow us
to you know start having a functioning
economy again as soon as possible
yes well um maybe a couple of
final points we can't say that the data
are phenomenal we can say that they're
going to be phenomenal whether or not
that actually reflects
the the the impact of these vaccines on
people why are the data
the data are going to be phenomenal
yeah um okay and the last thing i would
say though is that this brings us back
around
to what we started with we were talking
about the indications out of the very
young biden administration
i mean we talked about several things
that seemed positive rejoining
the who um the uh paris climate of
course paris climate occurred
yeah and i would just say that in each
of these two i think we need to be
cautious of the same
kind of um the two being the who and the
paris climate accord
uh yes um so the who
uh in principle should the u.s be uh
a very active member of the who sure but
there's a question about whether or not
the who is so compromised by allegiances
that in fact
we are stuck in the position of
effectively not having a viable
who and the fact of peter
dasic being on the who's task force to
determine the origin of sars kovi
ii in china is indicative of a deep kind
of corruption
right this is the last person who should
be on that committee and yet
he's there and again most positive gloss
is at the very least there's a conflict
of interest there there's a conflict of
interest and it may be driving and so
um if that is the case then the fact
that symbolically it makes sense to
participate in the world's mechanisms
for navigating health issues and things
like that
is in conflict with what the hell are we
going to do once the mechanisms are
captured we're going to have to do
something
unusual um with respect to the paris
climate accords i would say symbolically
speaking
this is great of course we should be
party to global accords
on managing resources like the
atmosphere
and protecting us from heat accumulation
on the other hand
uh it ain't a solution right it's
more or less symbolic at the level of
its effectiveness and if we were ever
going to get
to something useful we would have to
have a very frank global discussion and
that would include
figuring out you know what parts of
these models
uh actually indicate something how can
you validate them rather than pretending
that because the computer says that
something's going to happen
that it is what other data can we rely
on in order to calibrate our
belief or lack of belief in the models
etc
so can we promote international efforts
for actual alternative energy etc
right and with respect to uh dapple i
would say
i was very much not in favor of this
pipeline i don't like it but
um i mean you were you protested against
it yeah i did
um but back in whenever that was like
2016
2016 it would have been um but i want to
know
what the alternative is and i want a
net analysis right the idea of we're not
going to do this because our
constituents
don't like it is not good enough the
answer is well what are we going to do
and you know so uh i'm not interested in
the shell game where we pay
attention to the symbolism over here and
we don't
check out the net effect of the policy
change so in all of these cases i would
say
uh i remain to be convinced um and we
have to move beyond symbolism
and uh you know political corruption
and regulatory capture are uh
two of the biggest stories of our era
and we we're gonna have to
to find our way out of the very deep
hole they've dug for us
indeed well i think that brings us to
near the end of one more hour so this
here is near the end of the uh
the first hour of the dark horse podcast
yeah the first the first
hour so um we will be after a few
announcements here taking about a
15-minute break and then for those of
you listening
we will be back next week for those of
you watching if you care to
join us in about 15 minutes for our live
streamed q
a you can ask questions uh via super
chat now
or in the next hour and
um if you are interested in joining a
monthly private q a that we do on the
last sunday of every month
um you can join my patreon it's
heatherhyang
patreon and right now actually is the 48
hour window of opportunity to ask
questions we don't get to all the
questions that are asked
but we get to for a number of them and
it's an intimate enough community that
we're
able to look at the chat as it happens
and engage with people
who are there live and if you are on the
patreon and you don't see it live we
leave it up
for you to watch at any moment so if you
joined
at the 11 level right now you can ask a
question
that you're a patreon brett um the first
saturday and sunday of every month you
have a two-hour conversation
our private q a is two hours and you
have um private conversations yes
there's a
saturday one on questions of
good governance coalition of the willing
and a sunday one
on evolutionary dynamics sometimes
there's overlap between these things
sometimes they're very
distinct but in any case they're both
very lively good discussions so
consider joining them excellent um we
have
we have shirts and mugs and stickers and
such for sale at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
we try to put something new up at least
once every month we've only been doing
it for two months but um
you know i'm thinking the data are gonna
be phenomenal the data are gonna be
phenomenal
yeah phenomenal um
you can email darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com
for logistical questions like how do i
pose a question although if you're
listening right now and you wonder that
again super chat via youtube
and oh then another benefit of joining
either of our patreons is access to the
discord server
and so i guess one more thing yeah um
we are sooner or later going to need
some kind of
artist to do various cartoons and things
if you are a person with such skills
please get in touch with our moderator
and maybe send them a sample of your
work
because uh we have gotten to the limit
of our
drawing skills which in my case are
incredibly limited so again
darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com uh yeah we're interested
in in working with an illustrator who
can do
obviously representative line drawings
uh and i can do a few things but
not that much all right well thanks for
joining us everybody we will see those
of you watching on youtube in 15 minutes
and uh get outside yeah we will
[Music]
[Music]
you